pendant quelques instants au ballet des
photographes qui vont venir prendre en
photo le ministre et puis dans trois
minutes ils vont repartir
et voilà
là je crois qu'il y a de la pellicule
numérique
et numérique
merci à vous merci beaucoup
merci
on a une heure en fait on a une heure
merci chers collègues monsieur le
ministre merci de votre présence cet
après-midi j'indique aux collègues
évidemment que l'audition est
retransmise sur le site internet du
Sénat et que par ailleurs la durée de
notre réunion et de l'ordre d'une heure
1h10 le ministre devant se rendre à une
réunion pour 18h se faire de ma part
c'est le ministre vous avez accepté de
venir cet après-midi de vendre notre
commission pour évoquer la situation que
le pays vient de vivre il y a maintenant
plusieurs jours pour ne pas dire
plusieurs nuits
bien sûr que l'origine de l'événement
est un événement dramatique
mais en aucun cas cet événement
dramatique ne peut justifier les émeutes
qui ont eu lieu ensuite et la violence
j'allais dire la déferlante de violence
qui s'est
envahit le pays en tous les cas un grand
nombre de villes de villages vous l'avez
rappelé aux questions d'actualité de
toute nature y compris sur des critères
que nous n'avons pas l'habitude d'avoir
c'est-à-dire des villages paisibles voir
des communes paisibles j'en connais
quelques-unes qui ont été la cible
d'incendie d'automobile ou de bâtiments
ou de tirs de mortier
les images de télévision
ont montré la violence avec laquelle
cette situation a été a eu lieu vous
avez mobilisé beaucoup de personnels de
police bien sûr
les pompiers ont été mobilisés les
magistrats vous l'avez cela a été
rappelé ont été aussi mobilisés pour
apporter une réponse pénale rapide
mais il n'empêche que sur le fond les
questions demeure aujourd'hui si la
situation est apaisée nous devons sans
doute vous en féliciter il n'en demeure
pas moins que on s'interroge tous de
savoir pour combien de temps
et on s'interroge tous pour savoir quel
remède demain
ce que nous partageons comme constat et
c'est là-dessus que nous souhaiterions
vous entendre c'est qu'en réalité
mérit bibliothèque espace public
lieu communal au lieu d’état voire
tribunaux ont été attaqués incendiés y
compris la maison d'arrêt de Fresnes
en réalité on se rend compte aujourd'hui
que c'est la République
c'est l'autorité qui est attaquée d'une
façon générale
les événements d'hier au tribunal
judiciaire de Lyon à l'occasion de
l'audience qui devait juger les
personnes qui ont été arrêtées et
renvoyées devant le tribunal le fait que
cette audience ait été suspendue parce
que des militants
d'ultra gauche était présent on
perturbait l'audience en insultant
d'ailleurs la police dans un lieu de
justice
sont autant d'éléments qui nous
interrogent sur la suite des événements
sur les motivations réelles des voyous
délinquants ou criminels
je ne parle même pas des agressions
portées à l'égard des élus bien sûr
les événements récents concernant le
maire de la commune de
L'Haÿ-les-Roses mais je rappelle quand
même de louisblions pas trop vite le
maire de Saint-Brévin je rappelle madame
le Maire de Plougrescant je rappelle
beaucoup d'autres qui depuis ce système
manifesté pour dire qu'ils étaient les
victimes de violence
dans mon département amer à lui-même
était aussi
attaqué à son domicile
bref tout est dit la situation est
dramatique la réponse
policière et la remise en ordre est en
cours et vous l'avez menée et ne vous
soutenons la question de fond et de
savoir comment demain les choses
évolueront et comment nous réagirons aux
attaques contre la République mais non
cette situation nous voulons des
explications monsieur le ministre sur
qui a fait quoi comment comprendre les
choses et essayer de déterminer la
réalité des choses car nous sommes tous
bien convaincus ici que l'ensemble des
populations des quartiers appelés de
banlieue des quartiers difficiles sont
des gens qui ont envie de vivre
tranquille
qui ont envie d'éduquer leurs enfants
qui se sont inscrits évidemment dans la
République quel dans notre réplique
exactement et qui avec leurs moyens
essayent de évidemment vivre normalement
donc il est bien question de faire une
réflexion de fonds de ne pas faire masse
de tout de s'interroger précisément sur
les causes mais de bien c'est vous qui
pouvez nous donner cette analyse voilà
Monsieur le Miss je suis déjà beaucoup
trop long il y aura sans doute des
questions de la part des collègues mais
nous avons donc je vous le rappelle mes
chers collègues une heure de temps
merci monsieur le Président comme à
chaque fois que bien sûr une commission
des lois m'invite à expliquer l'élection
du gouvernement j'y réponds
favorablement je m'en excuse si vers 18h
comme je vous l'ai dit je vous demande
de quitter votre commission car je
préside d'autres régions de sécurité
puisque si la situation est calme elle
est à surveillée comme vous l'avez dit
vous-même monsieur le Président après
ces moments extrêmement difficiles
le mardi 27 juin
2023 à 8h16 avenue Frédéric et Irène
Joliot-Curie à Nanterre des effectifs de
la DOPC c'est à dire le service de
l'ordre public et de la circulation de
la préfecture de police ont voulu
procéder au contrôle d'un véhicule avec
trois individus à son bord qui
circulaient manifestement sur une voie
de bus le conducteur de la voiture
voiture immatriculée en Pologne mais non
signalé voler a refusé d'obtempérer
d'après le rapport de la police
nationale aux injonctions des policiers
puis est finie par couper le contact
passage François Arago à Nanterre le
conducteur a alors manifestement
subitement redémarré
le fonctionnaire de police comme tout le
monde l'a vu sur cette vidéo a fait
usage à une reprise son arme
administrative il s'agissait d'un
policier expérimenté de 38 ans qui ne
connaissaient aucune difficulté dans son
casier qu'elle avait été décorée à
plusieurs reprises il est accompagné par
un autre policier expérimenté de 40 ans
qui lui aussi ne connaissait pas de
difficultés particulière avec son
administration les véhicules a fini sa
course encastrant dans une barrière et
un poteau le conducteur qui
manifestement a été blessé au thorax
était en arrêt cardio-respiratoire les
effectifs de police qui sont arrivés en
prodigué un premier massage cardiaque
avant l'arrivée des sapeurs du Samu qui
ont pris de relais mais le conducteur
blessé a été déclaré des CD à 9h15 le
premier passager arrière toujours dans
le véhicule a été immédiatement
interpellé le deuxième passager non
identifiant des faits a pris la fuite il
a depuis chacun la vue était identifié
c'est-à-dire exprimé dans les médias il
a été contrôlé dans la nuit du samedi
1er juillet en violation d'un contrôle
judiciaire sur ses horaires de sortie
est placé en rétention judiciaire il a
été remis à l'issue de la mesure à ses
civiles en responsable puisque il était
comme le conducteur non majeur au moment
des faits le procureur de la République
a saisi l'inspection générale de la
police nationale et nous avons fait
pareil en administratif au même moment
et cela ont mené l'enquête vous avez vu
qu'ils ont mis en garde à vue les
policiers le policier qui a utilisé son
tir administratif au bout de 48 heures
le policier était présenté devant des
magistrats instructeurs une information
judiciaire était ouverte il a été mis en
examen et placé en détention provisoire
et m'appartient pas plus en amont de
discuter évidemment de l'enquête
judiciaire ni des suites judiciaires ce
sera évidemment
au parquet ou à la chancellerie de
communiquer à la suite évidemment de cet
événement absolument dramatique pour
lequel je crois très rapidement le
gouvernement a fait transparence et à
utiliser me semble-t-il les mots qu'il
convenait tout en rappelant que ce
policier a le droit comme toute personne
à la présomption d'innocence qui n'est
pas condamné définitivement il y a eu
une nuit celle qui a suivi immédiatement
qui aurait pu être une nuit de désordre
public et je voudrais ici dire que le
ministère de l'Intérieur s'est préparé
immédiatement au fait qu'il pouvait
avoir des manifestations et donc il a
mis en place un dispositif d'ordre
public et cette manifestation ces
manifestations n'ont pas eu lieu puisque
ce que nous avons constaté de la
première nuit ce sont des violences
urbaines à Nanterre c'est tout à fait
vrai mais dans d'autres villes de France
par effet de mimétisme de très
certainement on y reviendra et donc la
posture du ministère de l'Intérieur qui
est évidemment d'éviter un autre drame
passer à ma demande d'une position
d'ordre public à une position de lutte
contre les violences urbaines ce qui
explique à la fois la mobilisation de
moyens extrêmement différents mais aussi
la stratégie a mis en place par les
préfets sous mon autorité et saguirement
pas le préfet de police même s'il n'a
pas été le seul au rendez-vous bien sûr
de cette action je voudrais en remercier
ici les préfets les équipes de direction
générale de la police nationale la
gendarmerie nationale de la Préfecture
de Police de la DGSI qui a été également
mobilisé l'ensemble bien sûr des forces
de l'ordre y compris des sapeurs et des
prédices municipales qui ont contribué à
ce travail nous avons connu pendant ces
moments très difficiles donc je peux
compter ce moment difficile entre le 27
juin et aujourd'hui monsieur le
Président même si les deux dernières
nuits ont été extrêmement calmes
23878 feux de voie publique et
saguièrement des poubelles
12031 véhicules incendiés
2508 bâtiments incendiés ou dégradés
dont 273 bâtiments qui appartiennent aux
forces de l'ordre police nationale
gendarmerie ou police municipale vers
les pays municipales ont payé à l'autre
tribu à ces attaques inacceptables 105
mairies incendies ou dégradées 168
écoles on fait l'objet d'attaque qu'elle
soit et sur la même période 17 atteintes
aux élus ont été recentrés par le
mystère de l'Intérieur donc bien sûr le
cas de Monsieur le Maire de l'Aïd les
roses évidemment devant une violence
extrêmement forte et devant une posture
d'interpellation sont exigées par mes
soins
les services de la police nationale
gendarmerie ont procédé à 3500 5
interpellations dont 1373 dans la seule
zone de la préfecture de police
c'est-à-dire Paris et sa petite couronne
du notamment au fait que nous avons
demandé comme chacun a vu dès le
deuxième jour que les brigades
d'intervention qui d'habitude sont
utilisés en judiciaire je parle du raid
du GIGN de la Berry ou des pelons de la
gare de républicaine ont été mobilisés
dans toutes les villes de France et ont
procédé à ces très nombreuses
interpellations je crois dans des
conditions conformes à la loi et à la
déontologie et aux principes de
proportionnalité que je leur ai demandé
même s'il peut y avoir des moments
dramatiques et évidemment on entend ici
ou là le fait que cela puisse exister il
n'y a à ma connaissance que 10 saisit de
l'IGPN ou de l'iggn dans des cas
particuliers pour l'instant pour lequel
je n'ai que très peu d'informations et
pour le cas d'ailleurs des enquêtes
judiciaires te sont ouvertes je vais
donc remercier les policiers des
gendarmes puisqu'ils ont agi dans des
conditions difficiles on les a rappelé
de leur congés on a annulé des
formations on a rappelé des missions
comme les CRS des plages pour que bien
évidemment puissent répondre à cette
problématique on a organisé des
continuités de service qui était au-delà
des horaires je serai monsieur le
Président en tant que chef
d'administration Miss à l'intérieur les
remercier symboliquement et plus que
cela évidemment pour cette mobilisation
parce que c'est leur mobilisation et
leur professionnalisme qui a permis de
rassurer les élus limiter les attaques
même s'ils ont été extrêmement
nombreuses et je veux le dire ici
augmenter un nombre d'interpellations
jamais retenues qui a permis une réponse
pénale qui je crois est forte même si je
n'ai pas tous les chiffres et que on
sait tous que la réponse pénale met du
temps après les interpellations et les
garde à vue continuez à travailler de
police judiciaire je reviendrai monsieur
le garde monsieur le Président la
Commission des lois parce que nous avons
évidemment à travailler en judiciaire
pour pouvoir interpeller dans la journée
tous ceux qui commettaient des méfaits
la nuit et ça contribuer très largement
me semble-t-il au calme j'aurais
quelques exemples à vous donner et en
confiant la police judiciaire je
voudrais dire à Monsieur Durin peut-être
avec facétie simuler en préfigurant la
réforme de la police nationale nous
avons su je crois retrouver énormément
de monde et notamment énormément
interpellé de personnes dans la journée
qu'elles m'ont insigne partie des
ardeurs des émeutiers et des délinquants
et nous avons su me semble-t-il protéger
quelques symboles extrêmement forts et
nous avons vu transformer finalement ce
mouvement qui était des mouvements
d'attaque évidemment c'est un peu
caricatural parce qu'il faut regarder
territoire par territoire des attaques
symboles de la République école
commissariat mairie brigade de
gendarmerie poste de police municipale
centre socio en pillage de commerçants
qui étaient la deuxième phase si j'ose
dire de cette de cette série de nuit
extrêmement extrêmement difficile
en quelques mots monsieur le monsieur le
Président 45 000 forces de l'ordre ont
été mobilisées l'intégralité je l'ai dit
des forces ministères de l'intérieur
avec votre travail des services de
renseignement une très bonne
collaboration non seulement le
commissaire de la justice mais avec les
procureurs de la République qui ont su
je crois être au rendez-vous de la
travail très important fait par la
police et par la gendarmerie mais une
sociologie qui interroge la sociologie
des délinquants des émoticiens
interroges sur ces 3500 interpellations
j'ai l'occasion de le dire la moyenne
d'âge entre 17 et 18 ans elle a tendance
à augmenter un tout petit peu puisque
aujourd'hui ce que nous faisons c'est
que nous allons chercher un
interpellation des personnes qui ont été
soit par les travaux d'enquête
technologiques que chacun comprendra ici
récupérer des personnes un petit peu
plus âgées mais le dernier comptage que
j'avais c'est que la dernière la
première personne qui a été interpellée
à 11 ans et la dernière à 59 ans et que
si il y a une moyenne de 17 à 18 ans
pour ce qu'on a arrêté et que un tiers
mineur vous aurez donc compris que les
mineurs que nous avons interpellés sont
extrêmement jeunes pour la plupart Paul
part d'entre eux comme j'ai dit aux
questions gouvernement monsieur le
Président nous pouvons constater par
ailleurs que à notre connaissance seule
10% des personnes que nous avons
interpellées sur de nationalités non
françaises et d'ailleurs il y a eu 40
placements en centre de rétention
administratif ce qui est peu à vous le
sur 3500 personnes interpellées je
voudrais aussi souligner que comme j'ai
dit tout à l'heure à ma connaissance 60%
des personnes que nous avons interpellé
n'ont pas de casier judiciaire et ne
sont pas connus des services de police
cette évidemment difficile d'aller plus
au-delà de la sociologie de ces
personnes puisque après les
interpellations
ces personnes sont rentrées dans un
fichier qui s'appelle casiopée qui a
affiché judiciaire et il appartient sans
doute à monsieur le garde des sceaux
donner des informations dans quelques
jours je vois que c'est un peu trop tôt
pour qu'il puisse le faire sur la
composition exacte des personnes pour
que nous comprenions leur origine
géographique
de motivation éventuelle qui les ont
amenés à commettre ces méfaits
aujourd'hui monsieur le Président la
posture du ministère de l'intérieur
c'est évidemment d'être extrêmement
attentif ça repose sur trois grands
piliers le premier c'est une présence
des forces de l'ordre extrêmement forte
sur le territoire national je constate
avec vous que ni d'accords à quelques
exceptions près un peu la Guyane un peu
la Réunion mais très en deçà de ce
qu'elle fait la métropole donc il s'agit
d'un sujet exclusivement métropolitain
ou quasi exclusivement métropolitain
rester très éveillé donc pour la
présence de voies publiques et notamment
la nuit
je constate également au deuxième point
que le travail que nous devons mener
aujourd'hui c'est un travail de police
judiciaire il y a énormément
d'interpellations au moment où je vous
parle de personnes qui sont confondues
par la police technique et scientifique
nous avons particulièrement mobilisé par
les services bien sûr la préjudiciaire
qui permet de ces interpellations c'est
pour ça que les chiffres
d'interpellation augmentent qui
correspondent pas à des nuits d'émeutes
supplémentaires il correspondent au
travail de la PJ qui permet après
d'interpeller les personnes je pense pas
la mairie de mons-en-barœul où je me
suis rendu 9 personnes étaient arrêtées
et vous aurez constaté qu'il s'agit de
manière extrêmement majoritaire de
mineur et évidemment ça pose un certain
nombre de problèmes qu'on se posera
sociologiquement et politiquement plus
tard mais on a vu qu'en 48 heures les
services de la police étaient capables
alors qu'un feu avait ravagé une mairie
d'interpeller les personnes donc je le
remercier vraiment la grande
mobilisation des policiers qui font de
la police judiciaire et puis
troisièmement il s'agit maintenant de
lutter contre tout ce qui contribue
alors c'est pas une réponse structurelle
monsieur le Président de réponse
conjoncturelle à armer les émeutiers on
a eu peu de tirs contre les policiers
légendes je veux cependant au constater
qu'à Nîmes un policier a vu une balle de
9 mm dans son gilet barbal qui aurait pu
lui coûter sa vie ce n'avait pas été
bien équipé à Lyon en tout cas dans dans
les alentours de Lyon et les tirs à la
chevrotine contre des policiers qui ont
blessé plusieurs policiers on a vu ici
où là des alertes de personnes qui
auraient eu des armes longues et sur son
service souvent pour détruire des
relativement public ou des caméras de
vidéosurveillance parce que le travail
des émeutiers était assez organisé une
fois qu'on s'attarde sur ce point aussi
sur le fait que il détruisait d'abord
des caméras de vidéos surveillance par
exemple avant d'intervenir et donc nous
n'avons pas vu à ma connaissance de tir
d'armes dit type kalachnikov sur les
forces de l'ordre mais il était
maintenant c'est un risque très
important mais en revanche les mortiers
ont été particulièrement utilisés chacun
a pu le constater j'ai donc non
seulement demandé le lendemain de ces
émeutes de pouvoir faire que les préfets
sur tout le territoire national empêche
la construction la constitution de
cocktail Molotov et donc ne vendent plus
de l'essence en bidon dans les stations
essence la difficulté évidemment c'est
que l'essence est parfois récupéré
directement des voitures et donc ça
limite la portée mais enfin c'était
quand même déjà assez et c'est efficace
et interdisent la vente c'est pour ça
que les fermetures administratives de
magasins dans vos territoires le
contrôle au douanes et j'en remercie
mystère des grands publics pour les
contenu à l'étranger je pense notamment
vers l'Allemagne la Belgique qui permet
d'acheter plus facilement des mortiers
mais également dans les tirs dans les
contrôles de pardon de relais postaux et
de colis puisque des commandes sont
faites illégalement sur Internet ou de
transport de mortier vous avez vu par
exemple une affaire puisque la
préjudiciaire suit désormais
particulièrement c'est filières il n'y a
pas d'autres mots nous avons fait par
exemple 300 kg à Porte de Clignancourt
ce matin ou hier soir je ne sais plus
qui montre l'efficacité des services de
préjudiciaires il est évident qu'une
partie des mortiers était stockée pour
la nuit du 13 au 14 juillet et peut-être
a été anticipé comme marbe par
destination je pense d'ailleurs à des
élus qui ont été le fait de s'étire dans
la maire de Pontoise qui a été brûlée du
fait de la sœur de mortier par exemple
chacun a pu le constater voilà Monsieur
monsieur le Président en quelques mots
le fait déclenchant la façon dont a géré
les choses
mais la façon dont il compte les gérer
demain ou après-demain il est bien
difficile de savoir ce qui va se passer
dans les jours qui viennent nous
constatons cependant un calme revenu
partout sur le territoire national et
nous sommes toujours évidemment
extrêmement attentif aux heures et aux
jours qui viennent merci Monsieur le
Ministre plusieurs collègues ont demandé
la parole d'abord Madame Jacqueline
stage Brugnot Monsieur Jérôme Durin
Madame Brigitte l'airbier Monsieur
François bonhomme madame Marie-Pierre de
la Gontrie madame difolco monsieur
Lamarque monsieur le Président canner et
merci Monsieur Miss merci d'être venu
dans nous aujourd'hui je sais que votre
tâche n'est pas facile les tâches des
élus dont je fais partie n'est pas
facile non plus
moi tout d'abord je voulais rendre
hommage à la police au gendarme aux
pompiers du Val-d'Oise qui depuis des
nuits ne dorment pas et font face à
comme vous l'avez dit des émeutiers et
je pense que chacun d'entre nous doit
comprendre que la plupart des Français
soutiennent tous ces effectifs de police
de gendarmerie et de pompiers parce que
ce qu'il constate aujourd'hui je peux
vous dire qu'il y a aujourd'hui des
habitants qui s'expriment de manière
assez effrayante parfois et parce qu'ils
sont exaspérés les Français aujourd'hui
c'est la réalité donc on a beaucoup
parlé depuis quelques jours bon je
remercie vous nous avez donné des
informations certaines on les avait mais
je vous remercie de les avoir expliqué
je reviendrai pas sur le drame parce que
tout le monde constate que ce qui s'est
passé tiendra mais est-ce que ça
justifiait ce que nous avons vécu moi je
crois pas moi je le dis clairement ça ne
justifie pas ce que la France a connu ce
drame ne le justifie à aucun voilà ça
c'est clair alors on s'est beaucoup posé
de questions effectivement à juste titre
sur l'argent qu'on a dépensé depuis des
années pour certains quartiers et je
fais partie de ces élus qui s'est
beaucoup battu pour la petite de la
ville et je fais partie de ces élus
aujourd'hui qu'est-ce qui est soigne
beaucoup pour du ticket de cet argent
public qu'on a beaucoup dépensé donc
aujourd'hui je voudrais vous poser des
questions parce que il y a des sujets
dont on ne veut pas parler monsieur le
ministre mais je souhaite qu'on en parle
moi je vis pas dans le sixième dans le
7e ou dans le 8e je suis dans le 95 donc
voilà je voulais juste le préciser et
moi j'ai beaucoup travaillé pour faire
en sorte que tous les avants quelle que
soit leur origine et leur couleur de
peau vivent sur le code de la République
parce que je pense que c'est une chance
pour tous les enfants de ce pays quel
qu'il soit sauf qu'aujourd'hui force est
de constater que oui vous allez me dire
la plupart des gens qui ont été arrêtés
sont français d'accord mais ça ne veut
plus rien dire aujourd'hui ils sont
comment en français et moi ça
m'interroge donc je voudrais savoir
quand même si un jour afin que nous
puissions y travailler nous allons
pouvoir connaître quelles sont ses
enfants
issus l'immigration ici l'immigration
pour lequel probablement des choses ont
été ratées puisqu'ils ne considère pas
comme français puisqu'ils ont une haine
de la France que moi élue
malheureusement depuis quelques années
je n'ai jamais ressenti comme je le
ressens aujourd'hui cette haine de la
France certains gamins dans les
banlieues sont capables de dire à des
gens d'origine africaine totalement
intégrées tu es noir dehors mais tu es
blanc dedans c'est pas neutre cette
phrase ce n'est pas ne cette phrase donc
si on ne pose pas ça si on ne dit pas ça
et si on essaye pas de comprendre qu'il
y a quelque chose que collectivement on
a raté je pense que nous n'y arriverons
pas donc pourquoi ne pas un jour avoir
l'honnêteté nous dire que la plupart des
jeunes qui ont commis des exactions
depuis qu'à 5 jours sont
issus d'immigration c'est une réalité
ces factuelle et être dans l'ennemi dans
le déni ne nous permet pas d'avancer
voilà et moi je me pose une question qui
est responsable de cette haine de la
France alors que ce pays a accueilli
sans réserve parce que c'est normal
parce que c'est la générosité de la
France leurs parents leurs
grands-parents ça n'a posé le problème à
personne et que deux ou trois
générations après nous en sommes là donc
ne pas vouloir nous donner les chiffres
de ces mots issus l'immigration qui ont
pillé qui ont cassé ne nous permettra
pas d'avancer pour deux raisons c'est
que 16 ans mais non je voudrais juste
finir je voudrais juste finir ses
enfants là n'ont pas eu aussi au sein de
leur famille une transmission de leur
propre histoire parce qu'ils ont une
histoire ces enfants-là leurs parents
sont pas arrivés par hasard et c'est
aussi aux parents de transmettre
l'histoire familiale l'histoire
familiale elle se porte elle se trans et
elle se défend et si nous ne parlons pas
de cette réalité là monsieur le ministre
nous n'y arriverons pas merci madame
monsieur Durand oui pour être dans une
réalité qui n'est pas alternative parce
que je crois qu'il n'y a quand même
qu'une catégorie de Français les
Français et puis il y a ceux qui sont
les 10% qui ont été cités par le
ministre qui ne sont pas des Français
mais on va pas entrer quand même dans le
détail génétique des populations dont on
parlait un peu choquant les propos de
notre collègue monsieur le ministre je
vais d'abord vous dire que nous sommes
satisfaits du dispositif de sécurité qui
a mis en oeuvre on sait que les
situations étaient difficiles pour les
forces de l'ordre et qu'il a fallu
beaucoup de de coordination d'efforts de
leur part toute catégories confondues
pour que la situation qui était bien mal
engagée ça pèse et on espère que
l'apaisement dura je veux vous dire que
j'ai observé dans mon propre département
à Mâcon une excellente coordination sous
la houlette du préfet entre différentes
catégories de force de l'ordre les
gendarmes mobiles le GIGN le
commissariat local la BAC il faut rendre
hommage à tous ceux qui ont contribué à
autour de la paiement trois questions en
rafale
la Love Me et l'article
435-1 de du code de sécurité à
l'intérieur on a beaucoup débattu
pendant le pays du refus d'obtempérer
on était revenu sur la loi de 2017 j'ai
entendu le garder qu'il était pas
hostile à réama en la matière et
notre proposition de d'amendement et de
modification du texte et toujours sur la
table je voulais savoir si vous aviez
des chiffres comparés des refuses
d'obtempérer pour ce qui concerne d'un
côté la police et de ce côté la
gendarmerie qui pourrait peut-être nous
éclairer sur la façon dont ça se passe
sur le territoire national en la matière
deuxième sujet c'est celui
des déclarations d'un bloc syndical
majoritaire dans la police qui nous ont
beaucoup choqué tout à l'heure on s'est
mis aux questions gouvernement du
syndicat de la masse magistrature et de
ses propos j'aurais aimé aussi qu'on
puisse s'inquiéter de ce qui a été dit
dans un tract ou des syndicats policiers
voulaient s'en prendre aux nuisibles se
en guerre voire en résistance voilà je
pense que c'est très inquiétant et je
voulais savoir quel est votre réaction
sur ce sujet et puis dans une paysage
politique où il n'est plus d'extrême
gauche je voulais savoir ce que vous
pensez des milices des initiatives qui
sont produites sur l'ensemble du
territoire ou des
citoyens on sait qu'il y a eu quelques
militaires à Lorient ce sont organisés
spontanément pour venir en ordre aux
forces de l'ordre là aussi une forme
d'inquiétude nous habite merci merci
Monsieur durant Madame Brigitte
l'herbier
oui monsieur le ministre vous savez
évoqué un nombre important de mineurs
interpellé lors des émeutes le président
Macron a insisté sur la reprise en main
nécessaire de l'autorité parentale par
les parents sur ses enfants délinquants
je suis absolument d'accord avec ce
besoin d'encadrement familial et où tout
au moins un encadrement éducatif chargé
d'autorité sur l'enfant j'aimerais
monsieur le ministre que vous soyez
quand même mon messager auprès de
monsieur le Président de la République
pour évoquer le besoin d'entendre aussi
les enfants en bas âge en souffrance
dans leur foyer
270 enfants sont sous ordonnés en
judiciaire de placement dans le Nord
depuis plusieurs mois
considérer en grand danger et
ses ordonnances ne sont pas suivies des
faits faute de place dans les foyers
largement occupé par les mineurs
étrangers isolés et par la difficulté à
recruter des nouvelles assistantes
familiales compétente
professionnellement et moralement si
l'enfant était éduqué dans une violence
dès son plus jeune âge comment trouver
un échappatoire rien excuse les dégâts
occasionner ces derniers jours rien rien
ne justifierait de ne pas appliquer des
peines exemplaires tant aux mineurs
violents qu'à leur famille indifférente
à l'avenir de leur progéniture les
selles abandon rien car ces actes sont
inqualifiables impensables honteux et
nous remercions les forces de l'ordre
d'avoir été en première ligne merci
aussi aux pompiers aux élus symboles
visés par ces attaques mais on va devoir
travailler ensemble pour sauver notre
République
le président buffet et les membres de la
commission des lois sont prêts à
réfléchir sereinement pour éviter la
reprise de ce genre d'attaque
je pense qu'en amont un travail de
reprise en main de la situation de
l'enfant sans danger est inévitable les
départements font de leur mieux mais
l'État doit les soutenir en priorité
dans leurs actions les enfants engagés
appellent depuis des mois voire des
années au secours le nombre de violences
familiales explosent les procureurs
généraux viennent d'ici régulièrement
l'évoquer au sein du Sénat
ne laissons pas les enfants évoluer dans
ces violences car il le reproduiront
peut-être si rien n'est fait monsieur le
ministre vous qui êtes proche des
concitoyens et je suis bien placé pour
le savoir à Tourcoing transmettez à
monsieur le Président qu'il est grand
temps de sauver les enfants en bas âge
ces situations que je viens d'évoquer
sont en parallèle de notre réflexion sur
la violence de ces derniers jours mais
tout est lié pour comprendre et
travailler sur l'avenir
je voudrais savoir ce que vous pensez de
tous non non c'était pas sûr que j'ai
bien entendu Monsieur Bonhomme
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre comme beaucoup en regardant les
images de ces derniers jours je me suis
posé la question suivante comment un
fait divers tragique au demeurant a pu
mettre à feu et ascendre tant de vie
dans notre pays je crois que c'est la
première fois qu'on a vu un tel
déferlement de violence nous je suis
comme la majorité des Français a très
grande majorité j'ai un mélange de
sidération de stupeur de tristesse et de
solidarité totale à l'égard de nos
forces de sécurité policier gendarme et
sapeurs-pompiers les dégâts que nous
avons que cela occasionné sont
considérables et il va falloir payer et
remettre en état tous ces bâtiments
publics tous ces incendies tous ces
véhicules brûlés et indemniser tous les
commerçants qui ont été fortement
impactés
naturellement cela débouche sur beaucoup
de questions en interrogation qu'il ne
s'agira pas ce soir avec une simple
audition d'essayer de traiter je pense
que les semaines et les mois qui vont
arriver vont être l'occasion vraiment
d'aller sur le fond des choses
naturellement aussi je voudrais ajouter
que la colère ne serait en aucun cas
constitué un passeport pour la violence
de même que rien absolument rien ne
serait justifié excusez son usage
débridé vous avez donc monsieur le
ministre tout notre soutien sans
restriction face à la façon dont l'ordre
a été rétabli et si cela doit passer
dans les prochains mois par une analyse
profonde et nécessaire des causes on
pourra évidemment évoquer tout un tas
d'institutions ça n'est pas le ministère
de l'Intérieur qui est en cause c'est la
question évidemment de l'école de notre
rapport en France à l'autorité à tout ce
qui est verticale à la contestation
Toutes les figure de l'autorité qu'elles
soient juges qu'elle soit professeur
qu'elle soit mère ou qu'elle soit force
et qui a diffusé un sentiment de
déresponsabilité générale et sur fond
aussi quand même je voudrais le dire ici
d'un discours de complaisance ici et là
qui consiste à faire porter la
responsabilité sur d'autres causes qui
ne sont pas majeures en espèces je parle
la cause du racisme la cause de
l'insuffisance de la politique de la
ville le mépris social ou la
discrimination dont l'agent l'État
serait l'agent tout cela relève de la
simple dénégation du réel et nous mène
tout droit à une forme
d'irresponsabilité je rappelle que Ian
France qui tranquille et qui est
silencieuse qui elle a été également
sidérée par cette exposition de violence
et qu'elle attend d'abord un retour à la
paix à l'ordre et à la sécurité première
des libertés je voudrais maintenant vous
parler deux points et deux facteurs
particuliers qui me semblent avoir été
assez nouveau dans ces dans cette
explosion de violence d'abord le jeune
âge des émeutiers vous l'avez dit un
grand nombre de personnes interpellées
au moins de 16 ans ou moins de 17 ans
c'est une jeunesse ça a été indiqué par
le monde qui est devenu hyper connecté
mais dans le même temps complètement des
culturé complètement déstructuré
socialement et dépourvu de toute retenue
et totalement désinhibée je crois que là
ça marque vraiment et ça donne la mesure
du renoncement dans cet homme de de nos
institutions qui ont été complètement
affaiblis et affaissés je pense
naturellement à l'école et puis deuxième
une question particulière sur l'usage
détourné qui a été fait par les mortiers
d'artifice nous avons vu des images tout
à fait spectaculaires ou les les
émeutiers sont procurés moult et force
mortier d'artifice par tout moyen
comment se fait-il qu'aujourd'hui on se
procure en France aussi facilement on
achète aussi facilement sur Internet
notamment des mortiers d'artifices qui
servent uniquement à cibler nos forces
de l'ordre
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre vous avez depuis le début de
ces de ces difficultés et après la mort
du jeune Naël vous avez tenu des propos
que pour notre part nous avons trouvé
responsable
[Musique]
tentant évidemment au fil des événements
de faire en sorte que la paix civile
puisse revenir et on sait que dans ce
type de circonstances le pari n'est pas
gagné d'avance et nous l'avons vu vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure de manière
très responsable également
ce n'était pas exactement la formule
Mister pas loin bien malin celui qui
pense avoir la solution n'avait pas
utilisé exactement ces termes mais
c'était l'idée bienheureux voilà donc
effectivement gardons-nous de tout
Simplice mais de toute solution magique
il se pose cependant me semble-t-il
d'ores et déjà deux types de questions
auxquelles il nous faut répondre quand
je dis nous c'est parce que nous
considérons parlementaire que nous
sommes aussi acteurs de tout cela
la première c'est une question
d'ailleurs que mon collègue Jérôme
durain vous a posé sans doute en raison
du temps de réponse limité vous n'avez
pas pu y répondre complètement c'est
comment
réconcilier la police et la population
puisque sans être trop longue nous
voyons bien qu'il y a une difficulté de
ce point de vue là
et évidemment
comment faire face à ce qui peut être
perçu comme
une discrimination comme des pratiques
discriminatoires qui sont documentées et
comment faire face à ces situations sans
les nier sans les caricaturer nous les
caricaturons pas mais sans les nier et
je crains que certains ne les ne les ni
la deuxième chose c'est
les modalités de d'intervention des
forces de l'ordre
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que il est
nécessaire sans doute de recadrer ou de
préciser les modalités d'usage des armes
par les forces de l'ordre sans doute que
trois séances de tir par an et largement
insuffisant pour que les personnels
soient en situation de de réaction
suffisamment adaptée et donc au fond
toute la question de la formation des
policiers et sans doute en cause j'y
ajoute
sans doute la question de la
rémunération et au fond de la
considération que nous devons leur
apporter et on peut retrouver le serpent
de mer des millions d'heures
supplémentaires qui ne sont pas payées
et donc nous avons affaire évidemment
des forces de l'ordre exténuées et qui
ont évidemment beaucoup plus de
difficultés à accomplir leurs missions
sereinement voilà les deux questions que
je souhaitais poser
de la ganterie Madame Catherine difolco
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre moi je suis inquiète parce
que j'ai entendu je crois que c'est
samedi soir un reportage radiophonique
c'est un journaliste qui était place
Bellecour à Lyon et qui interviewait des
jeunes voilà et qui est si jeune disais
on va pas y aller ce soir parce que ils
sont trop nombreux effectivement il y
avait beaucoup de force de police il y
avait le raid de la BRI sans doute je
sais plus exactement je ne dis on va
rien faire ce soir ils sont trop
nombreux on revient mais t'inquiète pas
ne t'inquiète pas on va revenir quand ce
sera le moment on reviendra donc moi
j'allais dire je suis inquiète parce que
vous n'avez pas pouvoir disposer des
dispositifs que vous avez mis en place
que la préfecture a mis en place habitat
eternam donc dès que les dispositifs
seront allégés ça risque de reflammer de
nouveau donc que pensez-vous faire pour
éviter merci
merci Président je souhaite d'abord bien
évidemment comme d'autres collègues
rendre hommage ici aux forces de l'ordre
sapeurs-pompiers et dire à Monsieur le
Ministre que bien évidemment nous le
soutenons les uns et les autres ici
surtout c'est bon dans les actions qu'il
peut qu'il peut avoir pour protéger les
biens et les personnes sur notre
territoire nous sommes ici au Sénat les
représentants institutionnels et
constitutionnels des communes on sait le
rôle essentiel que représente les mers
au niveau certes des équipements publics
pour le mieux vivre de nos populations
mais aussi dans les nombreux litiges
qu'il parviennent à résoudre faisant
ainsi œuvre de justice de paix celle qui
a disparu dans les dans les années 50 je
crois savoir que vous avez donné des
consignes aux forces de l'ordre afin que
les élus soient protégés eux qui sont
aujourd'hui pris pour cible par ceux qui
ne supportent pas notre démocratie
pouvez-vous nous dire quelle forme
prendra désormais cette coopération
d'autre part comptez-vous travailler
avec le ministre de l'éducation
nationale cela rejoint des questions qui
ont été prélevées préalablement posées
afin que nous institutions soient aussi
à nouveau apprise dans les programmes
scolaires et que leur portée symbolique
est nécessaire au fonctionnement de
notre société soit assimilée
merci Monsieur Marc président canner
merci Monsieur président monsieur le
ministre
premier mot pour n'ont pas répondre à
Madame Stach brignaud mais quand même
pour rappeler cette phrase qui dira
sûrement des choses à certaines
personnes je la cite nous pensons que
l'immigration fait partie de la France
et des Français depuis toujours
l'immigration est un fait qui fait aussi
la France qui a fait son passé qui fera
sans doute son avenir il ne sert à rien
d'être contre que veut dire être contre
le mouvement des hommes sur la Terre
Gérald Darmanin décembre 2022 Assemblée
nationale monsieur le ministre j'aurais
pu signer votre déclaration je le dis
très simplement et je pense que il ne
faut pas avoir notamment entre sénateurs
madame chers collègues des propos
caricaturaux qui ne font que mettre de
l'huile sur le feu je le dis et je ferme
la parenthèse en la matière et je vous
invite à lire le l'excent ouvrage de
Monsieur héron François errant
professeur au Collège de France sur
l'immigration le grand dé ni
je reviens à notre sujet
initial monsieur le ministre
nous chercherons à comprendre les causes
et analyser et porter des propositions
d'ailleurs dans ce cadre au nom de mon
groupe j'ai demandé l'organisation d'un
débat parlementaire dans le cadre de
l'article 50-1 de la Constitution
j'espère que Madame borne pourra
répondre à cette sollicitation qui
relève de sa seule autorité
néanmoins nous avons une rencontre de
travail avec le Premier ministre il a 48
heures à Matignon avec l'ensemble des
prisons de groupe et j'ai pu rappeler au
nom de mon groupe ici représenté par
Madame de la ganterie et Monsieur du
Rhin
je me retourne pour savoir non à priori
j'ai interpellé combien de le faire
d'ailleurs notre collègue du Rhin sur la
formation des policiers sur
l'interprétation et l'évaluation de
l'article 435-1 du code de la sécurité
intérieure mais j'ai une question
complémentaire sur un sujet bien précis
mais qui prend toute sa place et son
importance dans le débat de ce jour à
savoir le développement et la
généralisation des caméras piétons
et
je ne vous cache pas ma surprise à la
réponse qui m'a été faite par la
première ministre me disant oui les
caméras piétons sont totalement
généralisées opérationnels moi j'y suis
très favorable depuis la loi égalité
citoyenneté de 2017 que nous avons porté
sur cette partie là avec Bernard
Cazeneuve et j'ai donc interrogé après
le ministre sur le fait est-ce que les
deux motards incriminés à Nanterre
portaient les caméras piétons il
n'emportait pas et par définition elles
n'ont pas été enclenchées puisque n'en
partait pas je considère nous
considérons que les caméras piétons ne
sont pas l'alpha Omega des solutions
mais permettent de sûrement d'apaiser
une relation entre incontrôlée et des
personnes qui apportent ce qui porte ce
contrôle et la réponse d'après ministre
m'a un peu étonné mais je veux pas vous
mettre en difficulté monsieur le
ministre mais me disant mais quand on
est motard on ne porte pas de caméra
piéton je ne vois pas ce qui
techniquement laisse à penser que pour
des motards il y aura un empêche ment
technique apporter les caméras piéton et
je pense que l'enquête du lycien ne peut
pas se baser uniquement sur de la vidéo
surveillance ou sur des visios faites
par des citoyens qui étaient présents à
ce moment-là s'il n'y avait pas eu de
vidéo surveillance et s'il n'avait pas
été présent ces citoyens filmant la
scène qu'est-ce qu'on aurait pu
interpréter du sujet donc je serais
heureux de vous entendre en la matière
merci même la présentation
oui merci monsieur le président monsieur
le ministre mes chers collègues bon je
vais me répéter d'autres l'ont dit avant
moi et c'est bien que nous le
partageions rien ne justifie
effectivement
les violences mais quand même rien ne
justifiait aussi la mort d'un enfant de
17 ans il faut que les choses soient
quand même claires de ce point de ce
point de vue là alors moi aussi j'étais
à la réunion convoquée par madame la
Première ministre mardi dernier et je
lui ai dit que nous avions déjà traversé
deux phases la première c'est la phase
de l'émotion
et la seconde c'est ce sont les
violences
inadmissibles que je condamne très
fortement et je ne reviens pas sur tout
ce qui a été saccagé dans notre pays et
les attaques scandaleuses contre des
élus et donc si la situation est moins
tendue aujourd'hui je crois que nous
devons être clairvoyants nous ne sommes
pas à l'abri d'une possible troisième
phase donc dans ces conditions je pense
qu'il faut rapidement apporter des
réponses à court à moyen et à long terme
pour rester sur le champ de la sécurité
parce que j'aurais pu venir aussi sur
d'autres champs mais sur celui de la
sécurité et du maintien de l'ordre je
sais que l'équation entre la prévention
l'accompagnement et la protection que
doivent porter la police c'est cette
équation c'est un véritable défi
à relever par les policiers eux-mêmes au
quotidien c'est un métier difficile
d'être policier et je trouve que c'est
la situation est d'autant plus
inquiétante que
la classe enfin certaines personnes de
la classe politique
en rajoute fond de la surenchère des
amalgames douteux des propos qui bien
évidemment encore une fois font le lien
entre sécurité et immigration avec tout
le respect que j'ai pour vous Madame est
sage Prino et je ne reviendrai pas sur
les propos de Monsieur Kanner mais vous
voyez dans une cour d'école ou à la
sortie de l'école quand un gamin de 8
ans qui a le temps un peu bronzé
on pense que c'est un immigré alors que
c'est son arrière-grand-père qui est
arrivé en France c'est pas son
grand-père c'est pas son papa c'est son
arrière-grand-père ce môme et français
je suis française je suis française et
je suis allé si c'est la question c'est
ce que vous avez évoqué madame
hustachepriot et je dis attention
attention
vous mettez de l'huile sur le feu avec
vos propos
comme les femmes politiques et surtout
en tant que parlementaire on ne peut pas
s'exonérer d'un certain nombre de choses
certes le gouvernement propose des lois
mais ces lois ce sont les parlementaires
qui les votent donc nous sommes
responsables aussi de la situation nous
avons des responsabilités et il serait
quand même assez inquiétant de
s'exonérer de ces responsabilités nous
votons la loi et donc les missions qui
sont confiées aux policiers c'est nous
qui lui avons qui leur avons conféré ces
missions et donc monsieur le ministre
moi vous savez j'ai plusieurs dadas
concernant les policiers celui de la
formation bien évidemment des policiers
je pense qu'il faut la renforcer tout en
tant que la durée de formation et puis
celui du retour à une police de
proximité je suis désolé depuis qu'il
n'existe plus de police de proximité
partout dans notre pays les liens se
sont délités entre
je n'ai pas dit que c'était la faute à
Sarkozy madame madame Stach Brugnot vous
savez j'ai loué très fine mais c'est un
constat depuis qu'il n'y a plus de
police de proximité dans notre pays les
liens se sont délités entre les forces
de police et la jeunesse et moi
j'aimerais bien que Monsieur le Ministre
répondent est-ce qu'il a l'intention de
revenir à cette fonction de nos
policiers merci Madame la présente
Madame la présente Gatel merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre merci
très sincère pour votre total engagement
et votre transparence et merci aussi à
toutes les forces de l'ordre qui sont si
sollicités si éprouvées et parfois même
accablé mes collègues ont chacun
évoquaient un angle des choses et ceci
montre bien que nous devons être
aujourd'hui dans une approche systémique
parce que je crois que les causes et les
réponses sont multi FLAC factorielle et
qu'au-delà de la crise que nous
traversons je pense que le mal est
profond et que la révolte sous toutes
ses formes y compris dans nos campagnes
parce qu'aujourd'hui on parle des
révoltes
urbaines il y a quelques temps parlait
de la révolte des ruraux tout cela
couvre et chacun de nous en tant des
personnes extrêmement modérées
aujourd'hui dire que demain elle
voteront différemment et que il n'y a
plus aucun tabou sur certains sujets et
que il y a une attente très forte de
retour alors de retour au vivre ensemble
et l'ordre vous l'avez dit vous-même et
la sécurité sur la meilleure protection
des plus faibles en tout cas si on
s'intéresse à la situation et au
comportement des plus jeunes en Afrique
je crois que l'on dit il faut tout un
village pour éduquer un enfant et je
pense que c'est très vrai je pense
monsieur le ministre vous n'êtes en vous
êtes en charge des questions de sécurité
mais on ne peut pas ne pas parler
tout le reste notamment en matière de
prévention la famille et le premier lieu
d'éducation il viendra l'idée de
personnes de rejeter le principe de
responsabilité individuelle et moi je
suis très sensible à l'interpellation de
notre collègue qui parle de la nécessité
parfois de protéger les enfants et de
les mettre à l'abri et leur donner une
chance de s'émanciper et de s'éduquer
parfois hélas en quittant leur famille
pour aller dans des lieux qui sont des
lieux d'éducation qui doivent être
positives la deuxième chose Monsieur le
Ministre c'est que je rejoins un peu la
présidente assassine dans les zones de
gendarmerie nous voyons que les
gendarmes vivent au milieu de la
population moi j'étais mère j'ai vu le
chef de gendarmerie est joué au foot
avec d'autres ses enfants allaient à la
même école moi je ne souhaite pas
transformer le policier en coach sportif
mais il n'empêche que quand vous
rencontrez les au quotidien dans votre
vie vous les regardez de manière
différente et vous n'êtes plus face à
face dans des moments de tension et de
violence et moi je crois à une présence
à plonçal la police de proximité sans
connotation d'époque voilà mais je crois
qu'il y a sans doute de la prévention
qui donnerait un rôle sans doute
différent à la police mais nous
préserverait enfin Monsieur le Ministre
dernière question s'adresse pas à vous
mais encore une fois moi je pense que
vous êtes au centre de tout et qu'il y a
une vraie question sur la mixité oui au
centre moi je suis très contente qu'on
dit ça bien heureux celui qui est au
sang sur le milieu bref je reviens
madame de la ganterie à mon propos je
pense qu'on a un vrai je pense qu'on a
un vrai sujet sur les conditions de vie
et l'assignation à résidence de
certaines personnes à la campagne comme
à la ville et je pense que si nous
confions aux élus locaux la gestion
notamment du logement social je pense
qu'elle serait plus heureuse parce qu'il
y aurait une mixité sociale qui serait
pratiqué en matière de dentelle et je
pense que sans doute qu'il y aurait
moins de tension et moins de ghetto
qu'en pensez-vous monsieur ça devait se
terminer par une question je vous
remercie merci dernière intervention
madame Dominique verrière merci monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Ministre moi je
voudrais tout d'abord
saluer en fait les habitants de ces
quartiers politiques de la ville qui
pour beaucoup se sont engagés pour
sauver des bâtiments et ne pas forcément
laisser faire essayer d'empêcher toutes
ces détériorations car ils n'ont pas
oublié qu'ils en étaient les premières
victimes et nous ne devons pas l'oublier
non plus donc je voulais le saluer
derrière ces émeutes il semblerait qu'il
y ait quand même une organisation
facilitée par les messageries ou les
réseaux sociaux soit mais une
organisation et d'ailleurs le fait que
vous ayez tout d'abord arrêter des
jeunes et que plus vous avancez dans vos
investigations et plus vous arrêtez des
plus vieux montre là encore qu'il doit
bien y avoir une organisation alors
quelle est ce type d'organisation est-ce
que ce serait lié au trafic de drogue
comme on le dit souvent qui profite de
ce chaos par ailleurs on voit vous
l'avez dit vous-même que vous avez les
forces de sécurité intérieure on saisit
encore 300 kg de mortier si j'ai bien
compris
sont-ils en train de se réarmer doit-on
effectivement le craindre et ça je me
fais donc l'écho de ce que vient de dire
notre collègue Catherine difolco et donc
que faire pour anéantir le pouvoir de
cela et enfin j'arrive au maire
célibataire alors je crois vraiment à
l'autorité parentale et je crois pas que
une mère soit forcément plus faible
qu'un homme mais malgré tout le maire de
l'ail des roses elle a dit lui-même
certaines mères n'y arrivent plus voir
sont elles-mêmes victimes de leurs
enfants qui souvent sont tombés sous
l'influence de ces fameuses
organisateurs dont je parlais un peu
plus avant alors moi je vais vous parler
des pairs où sont-ils les pairs et
permettez-moi de pousser un coup de
gueule quand je vois le père de Noël qui
se porte partie civile
il ne faut quand même pas avoir beaucoup
de fierté pour ne pas avoir été là pour
élever son enfant mais essayer de
profiter de sa mort
merci Madame Verrien bien heureux
interventions
nous appartient maintenant de répondre
un peu plus de 5 minutes quand même
merci c'est gentil merci monsieur le
Président
peut-être deux mots deux mots généraux
et puis répondre à chacune de vos
questions il a été fait référence dans
les médias et même ici ou là par vous
interventions aux émeutes dites de 2005
je voudrais comparer des choses et
évidemment dire qu'il y a des choses
très différentes en 2005 à 21 jours
d'émeutes et au bout du dixième jour le
gouvernement de la République sur
demande du Président de la République si
je me rappelle dans l'histoire politique
impose à son ministre de l'Intérieur de
l'époque l'état d'urgence
on voit que d'ailleurs ça a duré malgré
l'état d'urgence puis c'est plus de
jours d'émeutes après qu'avant et chacun
se rappelle sans doute que c'est une
vague de froid extrêmement forte qui a
calmé une partie des ardeurs des
délinquants ou des émotiers de l'époque
ils étaient plus âgés beaucoup plus âgés
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai demandé qu'on sorte
les comparaisons je ne les ai pas encore
mais à coup sûr ils étaient plus âgés
moins de villes étaient concernées
chacun se rappelle d'ailleurs que
Marseille à l'époque n'avait pas connu
des meute parce qu'on expliquait que le
trafic de drogue qu'elle met les ardeurs
de ceux qui voulaient être ébutier il
n'y avait pas de réseaux sociaux il me
semble que LCI devait être la seule la
chaîne de formation continue mais je
n'ai plus de bons souvenirs en tout cas
c'était pas tout à fait le moment
médiatique et le même nom de mimétique
et il y avait malgré tout
il y avait eu malgré tout à l'époque
d'abord de la part me semble-t-il des
décideurs politiques à défaut de
jugement sur ce qui était arrivé dans
l'affaire initiale et par ailleurs qui a
sans doute contribué
à l'excitation et à des vacances et par
ailleurs à la fin je constate qu'il y
avait aussi des revendications sociales
d'où les plans et notamment chacun s'en
souvient des fameux plan Borlo et autres
qui ont répondu à ces difficultés là
nous avons des choses très différentes
quatre jours d'émeutes
nous avons
jusqu'à présent pas utiliser l'état
d'urgence d'ailleurs je constate que si
personne ne reproche et parfois ça nous
approcher médiatiquement mais nous en
revanche d'avoir pris l'état d'urgence
je suis pas sûr qu'il nous aurait
beaucoup aidé et d'ailleurs je n'ai pas
proposé au Président de la République à
la première ministre puisque l'état
d'urgence avec comme grand avantage
comme dans un
état d'urgence terroriste de faire des
perquisitions administratives l'idée de
donner au minimisateur les pouvoirs
qu'on les procureurs de la République ou
les juges comme là il n'y avait pas
d'organisation criminelle comme tels que
nous l'avons vu il y a d'autres
organisations j'y reviendrai même à ma
Satis et perquisitions administratives
sauf et on va pas à l'instant où nous en
parlions n'était pas d'une utilité d'une
grande efficacité j'ai fait le pari que
la démonstration de force et
d'interpellation était de nature à
calmer une partie des émeutiers dont je
veux dire ici que d'après des services
de l'intérieur mais ce sont des chiffres
qui forcément ne sont pas scientifiques
ils étaient entre 8000 et 12000
peut-être un peu plus peut-être un peu
moins les groupes très mobiles souvent
cagoulés mais on peut pas considérer
qu'il y avait des centaines de milliers
de personnes dans ces quartiers ou des
millions de personnes vivent qui se sont
rebeller contre la République donc je
pense que même si les images sont
extrêmement choquantes même si les
agitations et les dégradations sont
extrêmement fortes même s'il y a 800
policiers gendarmes blessés fort
heureusement aucun n'a le pronostic
vital engagé je veux aussi dire qu'il
s'agit de toutes opus de quelques
milliers de personnes qui ont commis ces
difficultés ce qui est à la fois un
problème très important et en même temps
nous ne permet pas de mettre dans le
même sac tous les habitants des
quartiers populaires bon
le deuxième sujet que je voudrais
évoquer avec vous c'est celui de la
police
d'ailleurs je reviendrai peut-être pour
répondre à Madame de La Gontrie je m'en
excuse auprès du sénateur du Rhin et qui
connaît le respect que m'inspire son
travail si je n'ai pas été très complet
pendant la question au gouvernement
évidemment
la police nationale et avec la
gendarmerie je trouve que le débat peut
gendarmerie
je l'entends monter mais il est pas très
correct d'abord parce que il y a 25% des
vacances aux autres gendarmerie 75% zone
police chacun s'accordera à dire que
c'est pas le même type de délinquance
deuxièmement il y a encore quelques
années vous discutiez avec le visiteur
de l'époque de la Réforme de la
gendarmerie nationale puisque dans
l'affaire des Traoré à Persan c'était
exactement les mêmes discussions autour
d'un supposé racisme de se poser mauvais
interpellation
il y a du bon dans la gendarmerie
nationale il y a du bon dans la police
nationale je crois qu'ils ne font pas
totalement le même métier je veux
constater avec vous cependant que 80%
d'intervention des gendarmes mobiles
sont en zone police et d'ailleurs quand
on dit il y a un rapport police
population je pense que si on avait un
on peut toujours discuter d'ailleurs
j'aime pas trop ce mot parce que pour
moi la police à gendarmerie ils sont
dans la population ils sont pas à part
ils ont des enfants qui vont à l'école
ils ont des habitations qu'ils ont des
des maris des femmes des parents ils
changent de métier ils sont issus de la
population c'est pas une population à
part il rentre pas dans le caserne dans
le commissariat sans jamais rencontrer
leur boulanger ou leurs voisins bon donc
je trouve que les distinguer les
populations est insultant pour eux mais
je comprends ce qu'on veut dire par ce
mot je ne veux pas le rejeter par
principe je crois que il n'y a pas dans
le statut militaire de la gendarmerie
nationale dans sa formation des choses
qui expliquerait que ça irait mieux que
des gendarmes avec des policiers
puisqu'on peut trouver bien des exemples
qui montrent que dans les villes
qui se sont agrandis et qui sont en zone
gendarmerie c'est le cas dans je prends
l'exemple de Libourne par exemple en
Gironde ou c'est le cas de Persan ils
connaissent ces mêmes difficultés on
peut sans doute inspirer ici ou là des
pratiques des uns et des autres mais je
ne suis pas sûr qu'il y a une martingale
quelque part et en disant ça j'ai le
plus grand respect bien sûr pour le
travail des gendarmes pour le travail
des policiers le but du ministère
d'intérieur c'est de prendre le meilleur
des deux forces et pas le moins bon des
deux forces parce que aussi du moins bon
de chaque côté c'est pour ça qu'il faut
faire très attention en rapprochement on
aura l'occasion sans doute de parler de
la philosophie du cristal
je veux dire que la police
si on veut bien
mettre ça à son crédit elle est le
réceptacle tout ce qui n'a pas allé de
tout ce qui n'a pas aller jusqu'à
présent dans la société pour moi je vais
prendre un exemple qui voudra parler à
ceux qui sont attentifs aux questions
médicales ce sont les urgentistes de la
société si quelqu'un fume toute la
journée bois toute la journée
est stressé et en surcharge pondérale et
vit dans des conditions de non respect
de son corps il faut pas s'étonner qu'il
fasse une crise cardiaque ou un AVC
qu'est-ce qu'on fera on appellera les
pompiers ou le SAMU ils interviendront
le plus rapidement possible espérons-le
avec la formation la plus efficace
possible espérons-le avec les
technologies les plus modernes possibles
espérons-le et ils se vont ou pas la vie
de cette personne
si cette personne meurt nous serions
bien
comment dirais-je seront bien méchant de
considérer que c'est d'urgentiste qui a
pas su le sauver et qu'il faudrait
davantage encore le sélectionner
davantage encore exiger les choses de
lui sans doute qui peut encore
s'améliorer être plus rapide avant de
meilleurs moyens être plus attentif à la
médecine enfin c'est pas lui
personnellement qui est responsable de
cette mort ici cette personne ne meurt
pas qu'il l'a sauvé c'est pas lui qui va
lui faire changer d'attitude de ne plus
boire de ne plus manger de maigrir c'est
son médecin généraliste c'est
s'habitudes alimentaires c'est peut-être
même ses parents c'est peut-être même
son mode de vie donc je pense que la
police cristallise quand je dis la
police faisant les forces de l'ordre
cristallise évidemment des faits
médiatiques et extrêmement complexe ce
mystère de l'intérieur est un ministère
où tous les jours il se passe de très
nombreuses horreurs que fort
heureusement toute opinion ne connaît
pas parce que je crois qu'elle serait
alors aussi déprimé que les membres de
mon cabinet bien évidemment mais c'est
l'arrivée et après la police chacun le
sait la justice l'arrivée de toutes la
difficulté que la société a pas su
réglée avant donc moi je veux bien tout
ce qu'on veut et les policiers parfois
connaissent des difficultés fortes y
compris dans leur vie personnelle
parfois de management qui sont
extrêmement toxiques mais je pense que
avant de poser ce genre de question
pourrait se dire qu'ils ont une charge
et une surcharge physique et
psychologique très grande quand
l'éducation va mieux quand l'intégration
a réussi quand le logement est efficace
parce qu'on sait tous qu'il y a des
liens entre tout ça et d'autres encore
alors je crois que il y aurait moins de
travail pour nos policiers alors
cependant pour répondre à la question de
la Gontrie très très concrètement même
la gorille merci de des propos que vous
avez tenus et merci d'ailleurs au groupe
socialiste au sens large et à tous ceux
qui sont ici d'avoir tenu ses propos
c'est un policier qui a été mis en
examen c'est pas tous les policiers qui
ont été mis en examen
alors est-ce qu'un policier peut
commettre des erreurs oui bien sûr
est-ce qu'il y a à améliorer la
formation sans aucun doute d'ailleurs
nous avons posé quatre mois de plus la
propositions
faut-il faire davantage sans doute sans
doute faut-il mieux sélectionner les
policiers très certainement je constate
avec vous si vous me le permettez que je
suis à la tête d'un ministère ou à part
les commissaires de police
ce que nous recrutons c'est souvent des
enfants pour reprendre notre mot de 18
de 19 de 20 ans qui n'ont pas fait de
très grandes études et qui choisissent
ce service de la nation par la police
gendarmerie je ne suis pas la tête mais
ça de la justice où les gens passent des
concours avec plus 4 bac + 5 ou
éducation nationale aux gens sont très
mal payés par ailleurs comme les
policiers mais enfin ils ont un capital
social très important
mettons-nous quelques instants à la
place d'un majorité majorité de jeunes
qui choisissent ce service de la police
et de gendarmerie que nous devons former
nous
ok oui ça demande une exigence
supplémentaire parce qu'en plus ces
personnes ont la contrainte légitime des
armes et donc par ailleurs une
responsabilité supplémentaire et à nous
savoir pourquoi et pour quelle raison
ils veulent rentrer dans la police
gendarmerie c'est la première question
que je pose à des policiers à des
gendarmes quand je les croise dans
l'école
on est tous toujours très touchés et il
y a parfois des questions qu'on peut se
poser donc 1 je veux dire que oui on
doit améliorer sans cesse et ce sera un
travail jamais terminé de travail des
policiers et des gendarmes sans aucun
doute je suis le premier à ne pas
accepter à son instant qu'on tutoie les
personnes
c'est inacceptable qu'on est 15 ans
qu'on soit étranger en situation
irrégulière ou qu'on soit présent
directeur général d'une société on ne
peut pas tutoyer les personnes alors
évidemment c'est plus facile à dire dans
les fauteuils du Sénat que sur le
terrain mais c'est la honneur de la
Prestation nationale nous ne sommes pas
une bande rivale contre une autre grande
rivale c'est d'ailleurs pour ça monsieur
Durand et vous le savez que j'ai pris à
sa tombe de décision lorsque j'ai vu des
policiers manifester en cagoule on n'est
pas une bande rivale contre une autre
grande rivale c'est pas ça la République
donc oui il faut sans cesse améliorer un
travail difficile de formation des
policiers oui vous avez raison Madame la
Gontrie trois tyran administratifs c'est
pas assez notamment les tirs dit en
mouvement parce que c'est ça la
difficulté quand je suis arrivé au
ministère de la table à la gaufrerie 60%
des policiers seulement vers leurs trois
tirs administratifs c'est leur
administration qui est responsable de
leur sécurité et la première chose que
fait l'igpet de l'iggène c'est de
vérifier que le policier a fait trois
tirs administratifs et s'il n'a pas fait
il le sanctionne mais c'est pas lui qui
refuse de faire toiture administratif
c'est qu'il y a pas assez de stand de
tir c'est qu'il y a pas assez de temps
pour la formation c'est nous les
employeurs de ces policiers qui savent
responsables vous avez raison il faut
largement améliorer ça je crois que la
loi que vous avez votée nous permet de
le faire
vous avez raison aussi également il faut
sans doute que nous nous posions des
questions de compréhension du monde dans
lequel vivent les policiers des
gendarmes peut-être que le policier et
le gendarme et c'est le cas de toute
personne qui travaille finalement dans
sa filière professionnelle ne se pose
pas assez de questions parce que par
manque de temps par manque de formation
par manque d'action de son
administration par management aussi la
question dans quel monde il évolue mais
cependant madame de La Gontrie
accordez-moi quand même
qu'on ne peut pas tout à fait dire qu'il
faut changer les lois j'entends la
question sur la loi de février 2017
que le gouvernement de Monsieur
Cazeneuve a proposé dans d'autres
circonstances très certainement c'est
pas parce qu'un policier ne respecte pas
la loi qu'il faut changer forcément
cette loi d'ailleurs je constate que
beaucoup veulent que désormais je dis
giver sous le coup de l'émotion non non
j'ai beaucoup
j'ai dit beaucoup
ce monsieur ce policier qui est encore
une fois a droit à la présomption
d'innocence et je ne suis pas procureur
de la réplique je ne suis pas juge
n'a manifestement de mon point de vue et
je ne suis pas spécialiste au sens
formateur de la question mais je me
posais évidemment poser des questions
avant d'apporter une réponse publique
mais seulement pas respecté la loi de
parce que quelqu'un ne respecte pas une
loi il faudrait la changer c'est absurde
si quelqu'un fait du 184 km/h sur
l'autoroute BC la vitesse excessive de
130 à 120 ne résoudra rien puisque par
définition il ne respecte pas cette
vitesse je ne dis pas qu'il ne faut pas
réfléchir à aux conditions d'emploi des
forces je dis que ça me paraît une
réponse trop rapide et trop facile
premièrement deuxièmement je veux dire
ici que
l'intervention de la police nationale
gendarmerie c'est la conséquence de 10
ans de difficultés entre pays qui ont
commencé avec des attentats
les attentats terroristes
un certain nombre de violences
inexcusables qui relève très souvent des
violences urbaines qui adressé parce que
le premier travail des policiers
gendarmes c'est souvent intervenir sur
des forçonnées où ils ouvrent le feu des
reflets d'obtempérer alors j'ai bien
compris les questions qui m'ont été
posées je vais vous donner les réponses
j'espère le plus précise possible sur
les refus de tempérer en 2022 il y en a
eu 25 800 fait connu par les services de
police et de gendarmerie c'est à dire en
moyenne un refusé tous les 20 minutes
5329 dans des circonstances exposant
directement à autrui le risque d'amor
de 2016 à 2022 il y a eu une hausse de
5,8% pour les refus et 27,3%
d'augmentation pour l'effet de refus
d'obtempérer dans les circonstances
exposant directement quelqu'un à la mort
et si je prends le travail qui est fait
par les policiers donc parce que je vous
ai donné les chiffres opérés simples et
c'est ce qu'on a constaté c'est pas ceux
qui existent au sens où les policiers de
rames sont pas là qui amènent un
policier demandant de s'arrêter en ayant
constaté la fraction on constate qu'ils
ont augmenté 220
6%, et de même que le nombre de
récidives par le même producteur d'un
véhicule augmenté de 155%
dans ces conditions est-ce que les
policiers légendaires notamment la loi
depuis 2017 augmentent leur intervention
pour tirer la réponse est non là encore
je veux dire que dans le débat qu'on a
eu c'est faux c'est pas parce qu'un
policier n'aurait pas respecté 2017 que
il y a une augmentation comme je l'ai lu
par 5 des tirs en zone police comme en
zone gendarmerie
en 2013 c'est le dernier enfin le
chiffre plutôt que j'ai
226 déclarations de tir opérationnelle
et accidentelle de manière générale
usage sur véhicule en mouvement 133
en 2016 donc au moment où j'imagine le
gouvernement de ce Cazeneuve a été
inspiré pour prendre sa législation 255
tirs administratifs 313
usages de larmes volontaires
opérationnels en position gendarmerie
181 sur véhicule en mouvement
en 2017 l'année de la loi 394 styles
opérationnels 313 pardon 429 pardon
usage de l'in volonté opérationnel et
sur les vécu un mouvement 255 prenons
l'exemple alors 2020 c'est une année
covid me paraît pas une bonne
comparaison mais 2021 qui était une
année covid à moitié 290 tirs
opérationnels 341
usages volonté opérationnels 201 sur les
clients mouvements 2022 qui est une
année pleine sans covid 285 déclarations
de tir opérationnels 317 usages d'armes
opérationnels 168 un véhicule en
mouvement c'est à dire que
l'apprentissage gendarmerie c'est le
contraire de ce qu'on raconte il y a de
plus en plus de tempérés et j'utilise de
moins en moins leurs armes ça c'est la
vérité des chiffres et j'ai le détail
police et gendarmerie si vous le
souhaitez monsieur le sénateur je
voulais passerai c'est exactement la
même chose dans les deux façons il n'y
en a pas une qui augmente et une qui
baisse les deux baisses
donc je crois que on peut se poser des
questions encore une fois mis à
l'intérieur devant
l'incroyable force qu'on les force de
l'ordre par définition et la contrariété
que nous console Parlement peut se poser
toutes les questions qu'il faut après
vous êtes d'accord avec moi que la loi
que vous venez de voter n'a pas encore
connu ses effets puisque nous sommes
dans la première année budgétaire de
cette transformation et encore une fois
nous avons augmenté de 4 mois la
formation c'est remonter d'un tiers nous
avons augmenté de 50% la formation
continue mais je veux dire que la police
et la gendarmerie contrairement à ce que
j'ai entendu et c'est tout à fait faux
ne tire pas plus qu'avant et oui les
autres opérés augmente bien plus
qu'avant ça pose des tas de questions
les gens qui conduisent sans permis les
gens qui viennent de cambrioler les gens
qui ont de la drogue les gens qui ont de
l'alcool les gens qui respectent plus
aucune autorité c'est tout à fait vrai
il y a sans doute beaucoup de raisons
assez refaire mais il n'est pas vrai
quand j'ai lu et relu et relu que nous
augmenterions les consignes de tir de
les tirs les consignes et donc les tirs
sur les les refuses sur les reflux alors
d'autres questions ont été posées alors
madame Serge Regnault vous posez une
question difficile
je vais essayer de répondre non
seulement ce que je pense mais je crois
être la vérité
je n'ai pas de réponse scientifique
puisque par définition nous n'avons pas
encore le retour exact de l'intégralité
des personnes que nous avons
interpellées je veux ici vous dire que
président de la République a demandé au
garder cela moi-même de postérieure à
aux interpellations au travail de la
justice de faire très rapidement une
étude sociologique pour savoir qui sont
ces personnes
et je suis certain que le Président de
la République nous autorisera à rendre
public cette étude sociologique je veux
le dire en dehors du travail des
policiers des gendarmes que des gens
extérieurs puissent regarder ce qui
s'est passé
moi je n'y ai pas vu j'ai fait une
quinzaine de commissariats en 4 jours la
nuit et la chose que je fais quand je
vous pose de garde c'est que je demande
la liste des personnes qui sont perdues
mais qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait jusqu'à
présent beaucoup dit que c'était des
gens provenant sur notre familiales on
peut tous faire l'expérience vous êtes
parlementaire vous y aider quand vous le
souhaitez bien évidemment ça vaut la
République j'ai regardé et faites-le
dans vos commissariats de gendarmerie
qui sont ces gens oui il y a des gens
qui apparemment pourraient être issus
d'immigration mais il y a eu beaucoup de
Kevin et de Matteo si je peux me
permettre
il y en a eu aussi et l'explication
n'est pas n'est pas
l'explication seulement identitaire me
paraît très erronée
je ne veux pas ici dire je pense qu'une
explication
identitaire serait se tromper et puis
surtout je pense que ce serait une
critique assez fort de ce qui s'est
apparemment parce que si je fais rapide
calcul 17 ans de moyenne c'est à dire
qu'ils sont nés sous la présidence de
Jacques Chirac ça veut dire que
reprocher aujourd'hui imaginez d'ici
Ferré immédiatement sur une question
migratoire
me paraît déjà trop tard madame la
sénatrice si jamais c'était votre
solution en revanche la question de
l'intégration et la réussite de
l'assimilation est une question
intéressante
et je crois que la posée simplement en
termes identitaire serait une réponse
trop facile mais encore une fois ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure il faut il faut
se poser sur les sur les sur les
questions
est-ce que l'explication sociale est la
seule réponse je ne le crois pas
totalement non plus d'abord ce serait
une insulte extrêmement forte à tous
ceux qui suivent des familles très
modestes
travaillent et respectent l'ordre et
c'est pas parce que on connaît des
situations très modestes qu'on attaque
des bibliothèques qu'on attaque des CCAS
on a attaqué des CCAS voilà chacun sait
ce que ça veut dire des postes dans des
quartiers populaires et vous savez très
concrètement moi dans ma ville ou dans
la ville de Reims que j'étais visité en
quartier populaire attaquer les deux
postes des deux quartiers populaires
c'est à dire que les minima sociaux qui
sont parfois critiqués c'est-à-dire des
mandats que le toucheront pas les gens
leur propre famille donc l'explication
ne peut pas être que sociale étant issue
d'immigration par ma famille et étant
issu une famille modeste par ma famille
je pense qu'il y a une part de liberté
de chaque individu de se sortir de son
déterminisme et que ce travail de la
République de l'aider à sortir se
déterminisme il peut y avoir des
réflexes identitaires aux communautaires
il peut y avoir des réflexes de classes
sociales mais je crois que le principe
de la République c'est de ne pas
discriminer les gens soit social soit
par leur classe d'origine éthique je ne
suis pas naïf madame la sénatrice je dis
juste que je ne veux pas confondre les
choses il me semble j'ai toujours
combattu les discours qui consistaient à
dire qu'il y avait des gens qui
intrinsèquement si j'ose dire
essentiellement au sens de l'essence
était prédéterminé sinon on aurait du
mal à comprendre comment beaucoup
d'entre eux servent dans l'armée
française dans la police française moi
je sais bien c'est parce que vous avez
dit mais ce que je veux dire c'est qu'il
y a aussi beaucoup d'enfants ici de
migration que je croise dans les
couloirs de la police nationale que je
croise à la mairie que je croise à la
gendarmerie nationale que je croise dans
les armées et je crois et je crois et je
crois que c'est une question plus
d'intégration
et d'action que fait la République pour
les aider à s'intégrer de
responsabilisation des personnes
individuellement que de déterminisme
d'origine ethnique ou sociale
je veux dire ce monsieur Durin que je
pense que j'ai répondu sur la levure
pour en parler à l'envie et sans doute
de manière un peu plus calme que j'ai
été
en désapprobation du communiqué du
syndicat Alliance et que j'ai été dit
même sur une chaîne de grand écoute
puisque c'était le journal de télévisé
de TF1 que ce n'était pas mes mots après
moi monsieur le centaure j'ai deux
réflexions personnelles la première
c'est que la liberté syndicale elle est
pour tout le monde
syndicale elle est pour tout le monde je
le corrige aucun communiqué d'aucun
syndicats bon oui encore heureux mais on
voudrait que je corrige et communiquer
du syndicat Alliance je ne suis pas
adhérent du syndicat Alliance ni des
autres syndicats par ailleurs et je ce
n'est pas moi de faire la police de la
pensée ils ont sorti à communiquer il y
a une discussion politique je crois
qu'il s'attendait à cette réaction
politique point j'ai dit aux
responsables d'alliance pour qui
personnellement j'ai le plus grand
respect comme pour tous les syndicats de
policiers qui font un travail très
compliqué très difficile et qui
défendent l'intérêt des fonctionnaires
de police que ça me paraissait pas les
mots que j'aurais utilisés dans le
contexte en plus dans lequel nous étions
point une fois que j'ai dit ça je veux
aussi dire par ailleurs
que beaucoup de policiers beaucoup de
gendarmes
tout en ayant peut-être un avis
identique à celui du communiqué du
syndicat Alliance ou on considérant que
les politiques n'en font pas assez vous
considérons que ils subissent beaucoup
de difficultés ou considérant comme
dirait même incontrie elle a
parfaitement raison même si nous
augmentons notre rémunération qui sont
mal payés
beaucoup de policiers et de gendarmes
ont été
malgré leur opinion politique
philosophique ou religieuse totalement
au rendez-vous de ce qu'a demandé la
République moi j'ai pas eu un mouvement
de grève un mouvement de désapprobation
et encore une fois je le redire même si
il y a 10 enquêtes igpn iggn et il faut
qu'elles aient jusqu'au bout avoir des
dizaines de milliers d'intervention pour
avoir 4000 interpellation dans un
contexte où les maisons brûlées on
envoyait le raid pour libérer des élus
dans des mairies on envoyait le GIGN
pour pouvoir arrêter des émeutiers des
types du GIGN que j'ai croisé
excusez-moi c'était que des garçons à
Torcy moi expliquer que dans des
communes où ils sont allés il y avait 50
et Métiers ils étaient 4 bon ils ont
arrêté ces personnes pour brûler une
mairie pour brûler une médiathèque moi
je veux leur dire que j'ai très bien
compris qu'ils avaient été au
rendez-vous de la République et qu'ils
avaient compris qu'on avait besoin d'eux
une fois que j'ai dit ça les syndicats
ils ont la liberté de dire ce qu'ils
souhaitent et vous avez le la liberté
bien évidemment ce sénateur de critiquer
ce sujet
la les milices que vous évoquez ont
existé à Angers et à Chambéry notamment
documenté par ministère de l'Intérieur
nous avons procédé à des interpellations
nous avons présenté ces personnes devant
la justice
nous verrons bien à quelle réponse
pénale ils auront je veux aussi dire que
des militants ultra gauche comme l'a dit
monsieur le président de la commission
des lois ont participé de façon
extrêmement rare mais quand même à des
attaques je pense au quartier du Mirail
à Toulouse notamment tout au début on va
essayer de faire ce qu'on appelle une
convergence des luttes
ils n'ont pas réussi et je veux dire ici
que moins de 2% des personnes que nous
avons interpellées sont connues des
services de renseignement et à ma
connaissance un seul fichier
donc on voit bien qu'il n'y a pas eu de
convergence des luttes même si ça avait
été souhaité
donc oui les milices d'extrême droite
doivent être absolument combattus nous
regarderons d'ailleurs comment on peut
documenter d'éventuelles dissolution
s'il existait des groupements familiaux
des associations on y travaille en ce
moment monsieur le sénateur et oui le
combat contre l'ultra gauche qui profite
et qui veut mettre bas notre système
républicain doit être également combattu
je veux dire par ailleurs que il y a eu
effectivement à Lorient manifestement
une mobilisation en dehors de tout cadre
bien sûr de certains militaires je
remercie le ministère des armées d'avoir
ouvert une enquête sur ce qui s'est
passé à Lorient à notre connaissance je
ne peux être que d'accord avec
l'intervention de Madame l'herbier il
passe simplement parce que je suis grand
électeur du Nord monsieur le monsieur
Président d'athmission je n'ai pas dit
pour qui je voter je n'ai pas dit pour
qui je voter monsieur le Président
canner et j'ai remarqué qu'en ce temps
de campagne satoriale vous avez dit du
bien du ministre de l'Intérieur et vous
l'avez me citer je saurai mon souvenir
je saurai mon souvenir
d'autres convergences je veux dire
qu'elle a je crois parfaitement raison
et que et que là aussi je serai assez
curieux de savoir et peut-être que
l'étude de commander par le Président de
la République te permettra d'y répondre
combien de ces adolescents ou jeunes
adultes
faisaient partie de l'aide sociale à
l'enfance ou en tout cas ont connu un
parcours parental extrêmement détérioré
peut-être que non
peut-être que on peut considérer vous
connaissez bien ces sujets que lorsqu'on
connaît des difficultés extrêmement
fortes quand on est enfant on a tendance
à les reproduire Philippe Segal a une
jolie phrase disait l'adulte est
toujours l'enfant qu'il était je pense
que c'est c'est vrai et d'où
l'importance des parents évidemment et
du cadre familial sur les mortiers
monsieur le sénateur bonhomme je pense
avoir répondu tout à l'heure aux
questions gouvernement il faut
absolument les manger cette législation
qui nous permet peut-être de réglementer
bien sûr ce travail de de poursuite et
et d'action et de ces on en reparlera le
président de la République nous avons
dit travailler
sur la question
de l'action et vous parler de l'action à
Lyon madame la sénatrice moi aussi c'est
une étude que j'ai demandé au ministère
de l'intérieur j'ai eu l'impression
confusément dans les remontées j'ai fait
5 nuits de suite dans les centres
opérationnels que la des villes qui
avait une caméra de vidéo surveillance
et les villes qui permettaient à la
police nationale d'intervenir sur les
caméras vidéo surveillance je pense à la
ville de Lyon qui ne le permet pas
madame la sénatrice je crois qu'on a été
plus efficace que les villes qui avaient
pas de caméras sont nombreux ou qui
n'ont pas permis la police intervenir
c'est un fait je suis désolé de le dire
c'est un fait donc je crois que pour
corroborer c'est fait forcément confus
et peut-être avec un billet
psychologique de ma part nous avons
aussi demandé de regarder arrêt des
émeutes travail de la police judiciaire
et présence de caméra vidéoprotection
pour que la représentation nationale
puisqu'on a souvent ce débat puis savoir
ces éléments présents
à évoqué la question des caméras piétons
il a mille fois raison moi je salue le
travail qui a fait le ministre et le
premier Cazeneuve dans la loi qui est
parmi ces caméras piétons quand je suis
arrivé au ministère de l'Intérieur il y
avait 11000 caméras piétons il y en a
désormais 53000 et ils vont continuer à
augmenter je passerai monsieur
centerduin connaissa sur le fait que les
caméras piétons d’alors étaient pas très
performantes elle ne couvrait pas les
elle ne couvrait pas les vacances enfin
on essaye donc on a relancé le marché on
a équipé tout ça soit désormais
individualisé on sait quelle caméra ce
qui était pas le cas auparavant
appartient à qui et dans quelles
conditions demain on perd demain c'est
aujourd'hui puisqu'on le fait déjà dans
quelques commissariats grâce à la loi
sécurité globale que vous n'avez pas
voté mais c'est pas très grave mais le
président de la commission des lois et
la majorité l'ont voté mais je sais que
ce point aurait pu être partagé on va
pouvoir avoir le contenu des caméras en
direct également dans les centres
opérationnels
donc évidemment la consigne ministre de
l'intérieur comme pour le port du Rio et
pour les problèmes se durant il l'a vu
que j'ai rappelé à tous les effectifs
qui devaient évidemment le porter c'est
de porter ses caméras piétons oui comme
vous monsieur le Président le cananaire
j'étais extrêmement surpris que les
motards de la DOPC de les portent pas
je pensais au début à une faute de la
hiérarchie
ce n'est pas vrai pourquoi ils ne le
porte pas je me suis aperçu alors comme
quoi j'avoue bien volontiers une erreur
et j'aurais dû tel un maire tous les
jours dans sa dans les rues regardez ce
qui se passait dans sa ville parce que
les équipements des motards et pas que
de PC de tous les motards est-elle qui
ne permet pas de mettre le harnais qui
permet de mettre la caméra
c'est un problème technique bien
évidemment qu'on peut le résoudre bien
sûr qu'elle me tarde doivent porter leur
caméra piéton comme je suis ministre et
que je n'ai pas tendance à regarder en
dessous pour voir qui est à côté je dis
maxima mais elle coule pas nous allons
changer ça j'ai donné comme consigne que
d'ici la fin de l'année évidemment tous
les motards police et gendarmerie
puisque c'est le cas partout y compris
dans la gendarmerie national quand ils
ont leur moto de protection parce
qu'évidemment quand on est moteur on
peut tomber vous connaissez ces
difficultés et c'est pas n'importe quel
métier puis c'est très difficile d'être
motard il puisse porter évidemment leur
caméra piéton donc vous avez ainsi votre
votre réponse et je ne peux être que
d'accord
pour terminer je crois alors il y a la
question de l'organisation puis la
question de Madame assassin la présente
assassin
moi Madame A présente assassin j'ai pas
de d'idéologie pour la police parce que
je veux c'est que ça fonctionne dans les
meilleures conditions possibles
pour avoir été maire d'une commune
importante qui connaît des difficultés
qui a été aussi durement touchée moi il
me semble que mon commissariat c'est des
policiers de proximité j'ai des BST et
il faut un travail de proximité ils
connaissent les noms des médiateurs des
habitants et ils sont présents dans leur
territoire
et que c'est pas le travail des
policiers que de faire médiateur social
parce que c'est un autre travail et
d'ailleurs on demande pas médiateur
social de faire de faire policier il me
semble que la police municipale madame
la Présidente c'est une forme de police
de proximité
et je suis toujours étonné quand il y a
des mères qui disent il faut davantage
de proximité quand ils ont 100 200 300
policiers municipaux je peux dire c'est
bizarre parce que c'est comme le travail
que doit faire aussi une police
municipale qui doit arrêter de demander
toujours à mon avis davantage de moyens
si ce n'est pas déjà capable et beaucoup
de fond mais très bien un travail de
proximité maintenant qu'il faille
augmenter les effectifs pour qu'il soit
plus
en présence et moi en intervention la
réponse est oui c'est ce que c'est de
faire pourquoi on crée plus effectifs de
police nationale c'est pour que y ait de
des policiers qui bien sûr fassent des
interpellations
et d'autres qui soient en lien de
présence de voie publique ce qu'on
appelle plus de bleu dans la rue et
c'est pas la façon dont on donne des
consignes madame la Présidente il faut
bien comprendre ça qui perdent permet de
passer une police soit une autre c'est
le juste le manque d'effectifs
structurels global que nous avons qui ne
permet pas de répondre à tous les appels
17 ou à tous les appels de la police
judiciaire ou à tous les appels
d'interpellation pour qu'il y ait des
policiers de proximité ou de présence
qui puissent eux dire bonjour aux
commerçants être présent en bas des
tours des quartiers ou simplement
discuter avec les élus c'est pas une
question de consigne donnée parmi zata
par les préfets c'est juste qu'on a pas
assez d'effectif au moment où je vous
parle dans les grandes agglomérations
notamment pour répondre à toutes les
interpellations du 17
ce serait intéressant d'ailleurs que je
puisse vous livrer des augmentations
crescendo parce que tout le monde
appelle le 17 désormais et on l'a vu
d'ailleurs sur les violences
intra-famille et c'est très bien et la
présence donc on a un problème de RH
dans la police nationale à coup sûr et
d'ailleurs on essaie de le réparer peu à
peu donc
je veux bien en discuter à l'envie
madame la Présidente mais vous savez moi
je suis toujours étonné de deux choses
deux petits faits comme dirait Stendhal
le premier c'est un reportage que j'ai
vu à la télévision et et
c'était très étonnant il y avait un
monsieur cagoulé qui parlait à une
chaîne d'information on continue qui
disait ouais les policiers ils arrêtent
pas de nous contrôler et on fait rien on
ne fait que vendre du shit
alors évidemment si on a un rapport avec
la police qui consiste à pas contrôler
ceux qui vendent de la drogue on va voir
un problème parce que la police
proximité peut pas passer à côté et dire
tiens moi je suis de proximité donc
quand je vois un fait je n'interviens
pas deuxièmement j'étais au commissariat
de Dreux
parmi les très nombreux déplacements
j'arrive à l'étage au commissariat de
Dreux et puis il y avait Julien pour
dire bonjour le procureur de la
République il vient me saluer
et à côté il y avait une policière qui
faisait l'audition un jeune genre 14-15
ans je crois sa maman est l'avocate et
la maman veut dire monsieur ministre
c'est incroyable pourquoi on est là mon
fils n'a rien fait et là l'autorité
judiciaire rappelle quand même devant le
ministre que ben si ils son enfant à 3h
du matin était dans les rues de rue et
se servait dans des commerces qui
étaient pillés elle a répondu il a rien
fait il venait juste de prendre se
servir parce que c'est pas lui qui a
cassé la vitre
donc je pense qu'il y a sans doute une
part d'amélioration du travail du
ministère d'intérieur je ne veux pas
sous-estimer ce propos mais il y a une
part de la population qui ne reconnaît
plus l'autorité du tout et il y a une
part de la population madame la
Présidente pardon de vous le dire qui
et parfois complice de sa progéniture
nous avons des témoignages de parents
qui se servent pendant ses émeutes j'ai
un témoignage de la police de Paris il y
a 48 heures qui m'explique ils sont
allés interpeller un jeune mineur
responsable de d'avoir cassé un magasin
ils sont allés chez lui le père n'est
jamais ne s'est jamais levé du fauteuil
où il regardait sa télévision et lorsque
les policiers lui ont dit qu'il venaient
pour interpeller ses enfants il a dit
lequel qu'est-ce qu'il a encore fait
sans jamais se lever sans jamais
éteindre la télévision quand vous avez
ce genre de témoignage de policiers vous
vous dites que on peut toujours
améliorer l'information et la police
nationale mais peut-être qu'il y a aussi
une part pour la société
me semble-t-il que ne peut pas attendre
la population et puis enfin sur
l'organisation
je dis à madame la sénatrice que c'est
sans doute pas une organisation sauf si
je me fais des mentir par le travail
judiciaire évidemment donc sous toutes
réserve parce que c'est assez frais au
sens où nous l'entendons
au sens où cette organisé avec des gens
organisés avec du financement organisé
que c'était préparé c'était sans doute
spontané
donc le fait que les perquisitions
administratives des états d'urgence ne
m'ont pas parus évidents ça aurait été
une atteinte aux libertés publiques sans
pour autant en efficacité du travail de
la police bon je dis pas qu'il faut
jamais l'utiliser je dis jusque là j'ai
considéré que je n'avais pas besoin de
ça pour établir l'ordre
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que c'était
une organisation au sens
réseau du terme
et je crois que là les réseaux sociaux
sont très larges
interpellent dans leur effet mimétique
bien sûr la compétition
qui a été qui explique sans doute une
mobilisation de certaines villes
moyennes
qui n'existait pas en 2005
mais aussi par les messages qui se
passaient et vous savez le redire une
chose que j'ai déjà dit en commission
des lois je sais que les sénateurs sont
particulièrement attentifs aux libertés
publiques je voudrais redire d'ailleurs
que Miss des libertés publiques c'est
moi le mise et libertin deviennent cette
garde des sceaux mais la direction de
liberté publique c'est au ministère de
l'Intérieur
les écoutes téléphoniques à la papa ça
marche très peu désormais tout le monde
s'appelle sur WhatsApp sur telegram sur
signal sur les messageries ditescriptées
ou sur les réseaux sociaux type Facebook
snapchat Instagram le ministre de
l'Intérieur
n'a pas les moyens légaux vous le savez
très bien de regarder ces échanges de
formation là il peut le faire que dans
un cas très précis qui inca terroriste
que vous lui avez accordé donc je veux
dire aux Français qui reproche pourquoi
pourquoi ils interviennent pas je suis
habilis qui applique les lois de la
République je suis le pouvoir exécutif
une petite parcelle
je peux faire de la captation dite à
distance rentrer dans les téléphones
pour des sujets terroristes je ne peux
très contrôlé je demande des mises sur
écoute ou des
surveillances des réseaux sociaux qui
sont ensuite signés par trois autres
personnes et par une autorité
administrative indépendante que vous
additionnez d'ailleurs périodiquement
donc on ne fait pas ça la légère après
il y a de pouvoir judiciaire c'est un
autre sujet je ne peux pas demander
qu'on regarde Instagram Facebook
snapchat WhatsApp WhatsApp signal votre
téléphone
dans des cas de grande violence urbaines
de délinquance de trafic de drogue
donc je pense qu'il y a une question à
vous poser mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs si vous voulez
que la police et les moyens sous le
contrôle du juge et sous le contrôle des
autorités indépendantes
puissent casser les réseaux très
importants de trafic et notamment de
trafic de drogue
il va falloir bien un jour étudier la
possibilité que la police et la
gendarmerie et des yeux pour voir et des
oreilles pour écouter dans le cadre de
la législation et dans le cadre du
respect comme on l'a fait dans le cadre
des écoutes téléphoniques par exemple
et sinon pourquoi qu'est-ce que ça veut
dire ça veut dire que on va se retrouver
dans la même situation qu'aujourd'hui on
ne peut pas prévoir ce qui se passe on
ne peut pas savoir ce qui se passe et
c'est qu'au bout de 48 heures où on a
interpellé les personnes et on a ouvert
des enquêtes judiciaires et comme
l'exprimé garde des sceaux avec des mots
fleuris qu'on a pu
péter les comptes je crois que c'est ce
qu'a dit il garde des sceaux dans un
langage clair
oui mais en judiciaire le judiciaire est
donc toujours la conséquence d'un fait
là vous me demandez à moi des comptes en
tant que ministre de l'Intérieur donc
permettez-moi de vous dire que tant que
nous resterons dans ce genre de
fonctionnement nous aurons des résultats
judiciaires mais après des faits si vous
voulez l'administratif comme vous le
permettant d'écouter téléphonique
classique si vous voulez faire avant
l'effet il faudra donner les pouvoirs à
jour à la police à gendarmerie encadrée
je sais que c'est une question très
compliquée et je ne veux pas ici faire
d'annonces particulières j'ai eu
l'occasion plusieurs fois à me se
présente commission de l'avoir dit en
trois ans que je vous fréquente et que
je viens de dire dans votre mission donc
il y a eu organisation au sens réseau
moderne du terme
avec sans doute des mots du genre on va
d'abord casser les caméras de
vidéoprotection on va se coordonner pour
attaquer à la mairie machin bah non il y
a le raid donc du coup on va aller au
commerce bidule c'est ça l'organisation
c'est une organisation de de voler de
moineaux c'est pas une organisation au
sens criminel du thème du terme pardon
peut-être que demain ça évoluera ça je
ne sais pas mais cette organisation elle
a été très difficile dans la mesure où
les services de pays gendarmerie ne
peuvent pas c'est pas qui ne peuvent pas
en technique mais ne peuvent pas au sens
légal regardez ce qui se passe sur ces
réseaux que nous utilisons tous et si
nous notamment vous les utilisez peuvent
dit quotidienne vous imaginez que ceux
qui ont des choses à se reprocher ils
utilisent pour d'autres raisons et donc
je soumets à votre sagacité cette
réflexion parce que je crois que ça
explique bien des choses aussi dans le
fonctionnement de ces émeutes
délinquants
et pour toute ces explications la
réponse aux questions sans doute que
nous aurons l'occasion dans Red débattre
et que lorsque notamment vous aurez
d'autres éléments des éléments
supplémentaires mais un tout hypothèse
au moment de lever cette réunion je
voudrais redire notre entier soutien
mais notre volonté aussi d'aller
beaucoup plus loin et d'aller beaucoup
plus loin surtout sur l'analyse de fond
et la vérité des situations pour tenter
d'apporter une réponse qui s'opérait
évidemment qui soit surtout adapté merci
à vous